jodie foster bonsoir on dit vous même
que vous avez un ou même personnellement
un parcours de surdoué vous avez réalisé
un film qui s'appelle le petit homme
l'histoire d'un petit garçon d'une
intelligence tout à fait exceptionnels
élevés par une mère très simple
ce petit garçon est confiée une
institution et puis en fait cet enfant
père l'amour de sa mère et est
complètement déséquilibrée est ce que
est ce que c est ce qu il est bien de
placer ses enfants dans ce genre de
l'institution où est ce qu'il vaut mieux
garder au sein de la famille je ne sais
pas c'était une grande question
certainement les surdoué ou les enfants
prodiges comme on dit ils doivent être
quand même sont un cas spécial qui
doivent être un petit peu traités d'une
façon un petit peu différente parce que
quand même il se retrouve solitaire dans
leur vie c'était surtout sept thèmes là
qui m'intéressait le thème du solitaire
le prodige qui est nécessairement
solitaire parce que il va changer le
monde alors c'est lui qui dit de plus de
15,5 et c'est à dire qu'il va pas être
très populaire sur la conclusion du
petit homme alors ce petit garçon ils
arrivent à se balancer il arrive à
balancer les deux côtés de sa vie et
c'est à dire la côte et intellectuelles
et le côté émotionnel et ils arrivent à
se dire finalement bon d'accord je suis
différent mais peu importe c'est pas si
mal d'être différent de 10 foster je
vous remercie infiniment d'être sur
notre plateau je voulais vous dire que
j'apprécie beaucoup voient en anglais je
comprends tout fut très longtemps
vous êtes une actrice avec qui il est
très facile d'établir le contact c'est
le monde de votre dernier film réalisé
par robert zemeckis
c'est l'histoire des lits une petite
fille qui depuis son plus jeune âge
inscrite au télescope les espaces
infinis dont le silence effrayer blaise
pascal lui même un grand spectacle de
2h30 servi il faut le dire par votre
interprétation tout à fait magnifique
avant de vous retrouver et je vous
propose de voir le reportage sur ce film
de nicole camp de l'ong
ce bruit c'est un message crypté émanant
d'une intelligence extraterrestre ce
soit ce n'est pas locale position et les
cas 26 d'années lumière depuis son
enfance cet astronome surdoué a
manifesté une volonté exceptionnelle de
communiquer avec un autre monde
d'approché l'infini ensemble ces
contretemps professeur elle arrive à
convaincre un excentrique milliardaire
de l'aider oui monsieur vous avez votre
argent merci
imaginez une autre artiste jodie foster
pour apporter à la fois l'émotion et
l'intelligence de ce personnage est
capable d'incarner à l'affreux la
brillante scientifique réussi un
authentique être adapté d'un livre du
savant carl sagan
ce film montre non seulement le
comportement humain
la conquête scientifiques mais aussi le
débat philosophique sur la création de
l'univers
elle ne croit qu'en ce qu'elle voit et
lui ne croit qu'on dieu et constitue que
tu ne te fais pas d'illusion je veux
dire - g j'ai besoin de preuves de
preuves
tu aimais ton père elle part dans un
vaisseau spatial pour une autre galaxie
et ce voyage est évoquée avec les effets
spéciaux les plus sophistiquées mais
aussi avec des astuces artisanale
certaines scènes nous met en contact de
façon politique avec un autre univers et
la personnalité de jodie foster rend
crédible le fantastique
voilà il faut se faire une star au
contact des étoiles alors c'est un film
en quête de sens c'est une expression
que nous aimons beaucoup dans cette
rédaction
et dieu dans tout ça comme dirait
jacques chancel ce film traite d'une
façon un pas trop métaphysique de
l'éternelle question de l'existence de
dieu des rapports des interrogations des
scientifiques
oui pour un fini film de science fiction
où je dirais plutôt de sens science
factuelle
c'est un film surtout qu'ils traitent
l'humanité la relation de l'humanité
avec l'univers et ça veut dire que ça
passe ça demande beaucoup de questions
sur la science et la religion l endroit
ils peuvent coexister et s qui sait
s'ils peuvent coexister finalement vous
vous investissez beaucoup se croit dans
la préparation de films notamment de
celui là est ce que pour vous un film
c'est un investissement idéologique au
bon sens du terme ou simplement une
excitation cinématographique autrement
dit est-ce coupable donc vous pourriez
faire un film sur la peine de mort des
fonds dans la peine de mort si vous êtes
con si ce film est proposé par un très
très bon réalisateur
moi non je connais plein de gens qui
pensent différemment d'un pour moi faire
un film
oui c'est un grand un grand et un grand
acte pour moi je les fais très peu je
fais en général
un fois par an une fois par an et c'est
parce que j'arrive à trouver
traite naissance c'est difficile à
trouver quelque chose qui me touche dans
j'y crois vraiment puisque une fois par
an ça s'est vraiment investi dans la
préparation de ce film oui c'était un
grand homme vraiment un mental quand on
est une très très grande actrice comme
vous est ce qu'un petit problème de voir
de plus en plus l'arrivée du virtuel
dans le cinéma par an dans ce film on
voit bill clinton et ban qui n'a
évidemment pas tourner des scènes est-ce
que c'est pas un problème pour une
actrice de voir que finalement vous
allez être à l'avenir en place et
peut-être par des images faye a rien à
faire à la technique ça joue énormément
dans le temps et ses mains ce moment les
c'est quand même incroyable ce que ça a
pu faire dans ces dernières années il ya
alors il faut faire la paix parce qu'il
faut pas faire la guerre il ya rien à
faire ce film là par exemple c'est un
film qui est très technique qui ya
beaucoup d'effets spéciaux qui a
beaucoup glosé queen de choses comme ça
mais c'est notre job à nous en tant qu'
en tant qu acteur d'amener la
spontanéité dame et la passion d'un et
la vérité à un endroit où finalement il
ya très peu de réalité
parfois vous semblez pour regretter que
les états unis sont un peu le centre du
ont d'ailleurs dans ce film on a un
petit peu le sentiment parce que de
votre badge il ya la bannière étoilée
alors vous qui parlait très bien
français qui est très souvent en europe
qui défendent l cinéma européen est-ce
qu'on n'ait pas envie de tourner tout
simplement pas chez nous vous avez déjà
fait un film avec sa banque aient envie
de recommencer
non non absolument j'aimerais bien faire
un film en français mais pour le moment
moi je fais je fais des crises américain
j'essaie quand même de remonter la
qualité les films américains parce que
malheureusement on en fait trop et c'est
surtout ça le problème c'est que le
cinéma américain commence à suffoquer un
petit peu le marché mondial alors la
réponse c'est qu'il faut essayer de
faire les beaux films et si on fait des
bons films cd films internationaux s'est
défini par là tout le monde
elia royaume film le personnage dont je
joue quelqu'un d'international c'est un
scientifique qui pensent qu'il ne
devrait pas avoir les barrières entre
les entre les nationalités
merci beaucoup jodie foster donc sorti
de contact mercredi on va se dépêcher
parce que je vais vous emmener à la
cantine de france 2 et sa ferme à 21
une information pour terminer jean alesi
devant